this is Lea she is part of a
well-structured
IT ops team who are efficient and
reliable they deal with a high problem
load and perform extremely skilled tasks
easily the reason they are so efficient
is that they use IBM runbook automation
they weren't always like this at one
time the whole team was under increasing
pressure to solve routine as well as
complex problems like every business Lea
and her team needed to monitor multiple
applications and services this means
that IT ops and DevOps teams spent a
significant amount of time responding to
each and every incident that has an
impact on the business this resulted in
a significant amount of time lost
constantly trying to find solutions the
subject matter experts on our team have
created a number of manual
semi-automatic and even automatic run
books using IBM runbook automation now
when an event comes in Lea can search
using keywords see her run book choices
and even see comments that her
colleagues have left on the run books
let's follow Lea as she deals with a
typical problem here we see that an
application running on the server is not
responding normally Lea would have had
to search multiple wiki's or even
contact colleagues and multiple time
zones and locations to find the solution
now however with a simple search she has
already found a run book that seems to
be right to solve this incident parts of
this run book are even scripted so
instead of having to do multiple steps
which are prone to human error Lea has
to perform only - by using IBM runbook
automation Lea was able to save her
company money and prevent other
companies from losing revenue from
having their applications unavailable
with IBM runbook automation Leon team
had two deployment options they could
choose to run from the cloud or from
within their own firewalls IBM runbook
automation helps you become more
efficient reliable and cost-effective
visit IBM marketplace now to try your
free trial or to get more information
[Music]